el fuego parece incontrolable al sexto
día de incendios en grecia las llamas
dejan al menos dos víctimas fatales
miles de personas evacuadas y centenares
de hectáreas avanzadas varios países de
la unión europea enviaron aviones y
bomberos para ayudar a los equipos
griegos que se trasladaron a las zonas
afectadas para intentar controlar el
fuego
la cruz roja helénica está entregando
comida y suministros ámbar impone una de
las zonas a las afueras de atenas en la
capital berna ganador kirchner estamos
aquí para ayudar a las personas que
están en la primera línea al
departamento de bomberos a los
voluntarios a la policía griega y a los
ciudadanos esta catástrofe que no
quieres que te afecte exterior que más
las labores de control de incendios ya
han reducido algunos de los focos más
graves como en los suburbios del norte
de atenas el y de ifo sida
grupos de habitantes del suburbio
volvieron a sus hogares a pesar de las
advertencias de las autoridades y
encontraron graves daños en sus
viviendas
el incendio comenzó por ese lado y bajó
por toda esta zona
actualmente la peor situación la vive la
segunda isla más grande del país en
donde los incendios que comenzaron hace
cinco días aún no han podido ser
apagados entre el sábado en la noche y
el domingo en la mañana 83 personas
fueron sacadas de la isla grecia vive la
peor ola de calor en más de 30 años las
llamas han quemado bosques hogares y
negocios el primer ministro calificó
este verano como una pesadilla